[Music]
yesterday is a cancelled check and
tomorrow is an
IOU all you have is the moment what do
you choose to do with your moment and I
just started Living that it was it was
that that started resonating with me I
have the moment I am in complete and
total control over my seconds now I can
be as happy as I choose to be
and that is where I stay
empowering to have agency like that it's
wonderful this is your time yeah this is
nobody else's moment but yours what are
you going to think how you going to feel
you're going to laugh you're going to
cry what are you going to do with this
moment this now I don't wallow in
yesterday and I ain't really too worried
about how I'm going pay the rent
tomorrow because I got now yeah